very happy to have taylor hearn out
there tonight yeah let's go and take a
look at those season numbers 39 games in
total eight of those have been starts
it's been five straight starts for
taylor hearn now and he's been doing a
very nice job overall that era just the
tick under four right now
and there's a base hit out of the center
and that ball overrun
by tavares and t.a will end up at second
base
man at second with nobody out for luis
robert
there's a ball into center
tim around third is going to be held
with nobody out
double single to start the game here
comes jose abreu
3-2 to abreu hit in the air to center
and plenty deep enough
to get anderson and catch made by
tavares robert tags goes halfway and he
would have made it nothing on the sac
fly
minnesota the 3-2 there's a swing and a
miss and grandall strikes out two away
and that's the new addition for taylor
hearn he's been featuring it now for a
couple of months the two-seam fastball
so he gets really good arm side run jose
trevino is just sitting in the middle of
play he just wants a strike and you can
see the grip and then watch this pitch
just fade away from yes monte grandall
well hello jimenez he's been struggling
lately and a little comebacker makes for
an easy final out the white sox get a
run
dylan sees on for his 30th start that
leads the team is era a touch over four
a lot of strikeouts 202 of them
151 on the third inning
swing and a miss strike three looked
like a straight change and that was a
dandy he showed him a lot of fastballs
and then this was a perfect pitch just
kind of sits there at 81 miles an hour
no that looks like a curveball off-speed
breaking ball
swing in a miss right green that's
because he established the inside part
of the plate early he had garcia
thinking about it and then he wiped them
out with the breaking ball away
that's really a good hard slider not
many people going to hit that even if
you're looking outside
ground ball picked clean by freyju he
looks pretty good over there at first
base i might want to keep him there
one will lead it off here in the second
bounce
into left that will continue that streak
kind of a bad hop got by
hernandez and it will be a double for
yo-yo
so here's gonzalez
that's a base hit into the corner
will score gonzalez has a double it's
two nothing early trade places with him
is a good way to drive in your second
run and the second run of the ball game
one-two pitch to him and that looked
pretty good strength three called and he
is the second out of the inning
and he hits for a high average and he
belts that ball pretty well out to left
but peters is there
that'll end it white sox got another run
swing gonna miss strike three just
putting a little some spin on a 3-2
pitch and with dylan it really works
well especially upper regions of the
zone you just can't put them away with
one yet this time he does
on a curve
peter's just not going to hit a breaking
ball and dylan's knuckle curve is really
difficult i mean the spin is
as good as anybody's in baseball when he
gets it in the neighborhood you just
can't track it
he struck him out he's got five
strikeouts here early it's two nothing
socks after two
he got him looking no argument from
garcia he was guessing breaking ball and
he took one that had the whole plate
popped him up off of first
and abreu makes the grab and that's it
for the rangers
2-0 on romy gonzalez
out into right center that's gonna split
the alleyway
gonna stay in
and gonzales has a double
two for two nice start tonight just
walked billy hamilton and now has walked
tim anderson and the white sox have the
bases loaded luis robert lined a single
up the middle in the first
back on it tavares over his head
let's see how many can score there's tim
around third and he will get in easily
as the relay throw was never made
and they have busted it wide open five
to nothing
jose abreu digs in now
apple ripped down into left center
here comes robert sixth double of the
night and give jose another run knocked
in 111 he's
swing and a miss right three that's
seven tonight
didn't throw it where he wanted to yaz
wanted it inside he got it outside but
there's enough life on it to just
get it right by a very free swinging guy
right to robert
that's the quick one two three dylan
needed through four he's got a seven
nothing lead
extend his night
02 called strike three and he does
exactly that eight strikeouts tonight
for dylan cease
he went strikeout number nine for cease
you can see why he's got over 200
strikeouts coming into tonight
[Applause]
swing and a miss cease has ten
strikeouts seven nothing after five tony
gonzalez
pointing in on a possible division crown
he's got three hits tonight
cesar hernandez will take his swings
from the left side
make it three hours that's gonna get to
the wall
joel mcewing at thirds gonna send romy
crowe went back towards second
and it's eight to nothing
[Applause]
for all of his teammates it'll be a very
familiar mound for him
they get one
two
double play
that was with a guy that can really run
so that had to be a really snappy turn
at second base
cesar just turned it over they get two
of the ground ball nice play by yuan
this ball is actually behind him
popped him up so he makes contact
and jose will make the catch in foul
territory white sox win
in shutout fashion
magic number
from seven to five tonight coupled with
that cleveland loss getting closer yeah
it's ending in detroit just one of those
things that is inevitable the team
played very well just about every aspect
of the game tonight